[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVE ELLIOTT: Hello, and
welcome to Images & Video--
The Killer Use Case
for Cloud Storage.
I'm Dave Elliott, Product Lead,
responsible for storage here
in Google's Cloud Platform.
My background is storage, and
storage in the enterprise.
We're here today to
talk with you about some
of the unique challenges in
storing and accessing media,
and some innovative
solutions from Google.
JEFF KEMBER: I'm Jeff Kember,
and I'm a Cloud Solutions
Architect.
I've had the pleasure of
working at different companies,
such as ILM Pixar,
Framestore, and Blizzard.
I'm here to chat with you
today about some of the media
requirements, as
well as different use
cases from customers.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great.
So let's get started.
So today's agenda will
start with Jeff sharing
his experiences in
dealing with media,
and sharing some key
requirements for storing
and accessing video,
images, and audio files.
Then, I'll introduce
object storage
and cloud storage, and
discuss how they are well
suited to media assets.
Next, I'll briefly talk a little
bit about Google Cloud Storage,
and how it's differentiated
from other cloud object stores,
and we'll finish with a few
examples of where Google Cloud
Storage is used today.
Jeff, want to take it?
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely, Dave.
So I've spent most
of my career dealing
with large files of
disparate types and sizes,
and one of the
defining aspects for me
of media files is just how
many files you can have.
You can have many,
many small files.
You can have very,
very large files.
You can have files that
derive other files.
So if you have a mezzanine file,
for instance, for streaming,
you'll have the entire
film, and then you'll
have to produce 28
different flavors of it.
You'll have to
make different bit
rates, different
resolutions, different codecs
for different platforms,
and all of that storage
is challenging to
predict in size.
More complex,
though, is the fact
that users now have 4k
cameras in their pocket,
and they're shooting video.
There is applications that are
running on all the platforms
that are just ingesting a
massive amount of content.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And when we
talk about media files,
we're talking about
not just video,
but I assume audio
and images as well.
There's a lot of
similarities across all
of those types of files, right?
JEFF KEMBER: Correct.
Yeah.
So from a media
standpoint, I've been
working with audio files,
tons of imagery, video files,
and various hybrids of
those different types.
And the source files can be
kept in multiple versions,
and then recombined,
so you end up
having multiple versions
of the various files
in different stages
of production.
That's one of the size,
growth, scalability issues.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So size,
growth, scalability,
one of the kind of defining
features of all types of media.
OK, great.
Great.
So what else are you
seeing with media?
It's growing.
It's growing rapidly.
So how does that translate
into a requirement for storage?
JEFF KEMBER: Well,
we made a transition
from standard-def to
high-def many years ago,
and everything is
pretty much 1080p now.
And moving forward,
though, 4k has caught
on in the last couple of years.
We're seeing that
it's not a fad.
It's an actual
growth trend for us.
Customers are paying
for 4k content.
DAVE ELLIOTT: It's not a fad.
All right.
JEFF KEMBER: Not a fad.
Customers are also
interested in HDR.
And the standard will
be ratified before long
that will provide
even more color depth,
and that basically
gives you greater
film-like looks in terms of
shadow detail and brightness.
The image looks quite a bit more
lifelike than standard imagery
does today.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So these consume
enormous amounts of storage,
I assume.
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely.
When you go up in
resolution, and then
when you go up in color
depth, you very quickly
grow the size of the
file significantly.
And that is yet
another type of flavor
that you need to
make when you're
producing a video streaming
archive, for instance.
DAVE ELLIOTT: OK, OK.
So growth, huge issue.
So I assume scalability, then,
is a significant requirement
when we're talking
about designing storage
architectures for media.
So what else is important?
Protection?
JEFF KEMBER: Right.
Security is key.
You need to ensure that
only you have access
to the data, and
only the people you
grant access to have access
to the specific bits of data
you want.
An example would be if you have
a massive data archive that
is proprietary to
your company, you
want to ensure that
you can provide
just distribution
for elements of that
and have great controls
over who gets at that data
and, of course,
no one else does.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So access
control, encryption,
and things like that
are important when
you're storing these very,
very valuable assets.
JEFF KEMBER: Yes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: What about just,
generally, losing the assets?
What about durability?
JEFF KEMBER: Right.
It becomes very expensive
to have multiple copies,
and manage multiple copies, from
a version syncing standpoint
and such.
So having a highly durable,
single point, source is lovely.
Paying someone else to
manage that storage for you?
Extremely valuable.
When you do it
on-prem, you end up
having high
availability storage.
You have cooler storage.
You have mountains of tapes
that are stored, both on-prem
and in cold storage off.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And I imagine
this is how a lot of companies
do it today.
So high durability
is a key requirement.
And companies today likely
have multiple replicas in order
to meet that
durability requirement.
JEFF KEMBER: They're often
contract contractually
required to have three,
depending on the type of work.
DAVE ELLIOTT: What
about availability?
How important is that?
JEFF KEMBER: Yeah,
availability is critical.
On the project that
you may be working on,
having the media available
to you randomly is key.
If it takes you hours to
be able to pull the data
back, or even days, if you have
to online the data from tape,
and the tape may
not be on-premises,
it takes hours to get it, or
up to potentially three days,
to get the data back overnight,
online it, look at it,
and realize you didn't
restore enough of it,
or you restored too much
of it, and therefore it
took too long to restore.
And there's often
dependencies that
are found in that restored data
that then point to other data
that you, then, have
to repeat the process.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So on-demand
availability is key on that?
JEFF KEMBER: Correct.
And that was only
a local restore.
You're then in a scenario where,
if you have a global office
elsewhere and the data
is not local to them,
you have to work with the
time zone of that local office
to get that data back, and
then ship it to where you are.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Or imagine
a consumer that's in India
and might want to
listen to a music file,
or someone who's
in Paris may want
to see an image, a
photograph, that is stored
in some rich media file asset.
And so, the ability to
have that on-demand access
globally is important.
JEFF KEMBER: Yes.
Consumers are definitely
focused on getting
things on-demand and globally.
I mean, the web services
all provide that today.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great, great.
And then, I know you
also talk a little bit
about the importance,
from an availability
standpoint, of just generally
knowing what the heck you have.
JEFF KEMBER: Right.
Yes.
I've worked with customers
who have large vaults,
and I'm talking a cabinet
with hard drives in them,
and they'll be
handwritten post-it notes
with an elastic
band around them,
and that's the limit of
the knowledge of the data.
And they said, yes, the
people who wrote those notes
aren't here anymore, but we've
passed it down over time.
And that's unfortunate,
in the fact that
how do you get at that data?
You literally have to
take that hard drive
and mount it in a machine that
has the correct interface,
and then it's hopefully
running the right OS
to be able to pull
that data off,
and then you have
to sift through it.
That's a horribly expensive
task, in terms of human time.
And so the question is whether
or not that data actually
gets read again.
So the value of that
data may be really high,
but the usefulness of it, the
value of it, though, to you,
the IP owner, is really low, in
the fact you can't get at it.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Because
the cost is high.
Got it.
So a rich metadata
model might be
something that
would be valuable,
so that you can describe these
media assets in a rich way,
and be able to have easy
access, and essentially better
availability to them?
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great, great.
OK, so we've heard-- I guess
to summarize, what I've heard
is scalability is important.
JEFF KEMBER: Yes.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Media files
are growing incredibly fast.
Flexibility, so you need
to be able to support
small files and large files.
You need to be able to
self-describe the files,
or have the files described in
some way with rich metadata.
Security, protection,
durability,
and then, generally,
availability, are important.
JEFF KEMBER: Yes.
Yeah, the global availability
is really the exciting bit.
It's been challenging working in
the field with multiple offices
globally, and you're having to
rely on file synchronization,
dedicated links,
multiple file systems
in each of the
disparate offices that,
then, require synchronization.
There's a lot of overhead.
There's multiple people required
to make sure that system works.
With a central
global repository,
you can just have individuals
access the data they need.
For me, that's super
exciting from an availability
standpoint.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Fantastic.
Fantastic.
So now that we've
chatted some about
the interesting requirements
for storage, and storing media,
I'd like to touch on object
storage and cloud storage,
and how those fit many
of the requirements
that Jeff just mentioned.
Then, I'll introduce
cloud storage,
and provide a brief
overview of how Google Cloud
Storage is different.
So a blob store,
or an object store,
is a storage architecture
that manages data as objects,
versus a storage architecture,
like a file system, which
manages data as
a file hierarchy,
or block storage, which
manages data as blocks
within sectors or tracks.
So two tenets of
object storage that
make them popular choice for
managing media and media assets
are first, they're a flat,
flexible, and scalable system.
So traditional storage,
as I mentioned,
relies on file
system hierarchies,
which creates certain
upper limits on scalability
and performance.
Object storage doesn't
have that limitation.
As Jeff mentioned,
scalable performance
is a critical aspect of storing
and accessing media files.
Object storers also
provide flexibility
on the size of objects.
The second thing
is object storers
provide a robust and
flexible metadata
layer, metadata capabilities.
As objects are
stored with the data,
they also have an address
and this robust and flexible
metadata.
So the metadata
flexibility, compared
to other types of
storage, addresses
some of the
accessibility concerns
that Jeff mentioned earlier.
More metadata means better
access and better control.
So object storage isn't perfect.
It doesn't solve all problems.
But it does bring simplicity and
flexibility to access and scale
for storing media files.
If you understand
object storage,
and why it's such
a popular choice,
I'd like to touch
a little bit now
on object storage in the cloud.
Object storage in the cloud
adds additional benefits.
First, scale becomes global.
Jeff talked about scale
and how critical it was.
Scale becomes global
with global data centers.
So the larger the
cloud, the more capacity
you can use to store
your media assets that
may come during periods
of unpredictable growth.
So Google manages one of the
largest clouds in the world,
and supports many, many,
many exabytes of storage.
Next, object storage in the
cloud can be more available.
So major cloud
providers provide data
centers all over the globe.
At Google, we have more than 100
Edge locations in 33 countries.
Data will stay online,
which is in stark contrast
to tape storage.
Also, data can be accessed
with simple RESTful APIs.
Third, cloud storage should
be, could be, and likely is,
more durable.
A well constructed
cloud will deliver
highly redundant,
geographically diverse, storage.
In the case of
Google Cloud Storage,
we offer 11 9s durability across
all tiers of object storage.
And finally, a well
constructed cloud
should be even more secure.
While a few years
ago, some people
believed cloud was less
secure because they didn't
manage security themselves.
Today, I think most people agree
that a well run cloud provider
benefits from having a very,
very large, and very focused,
team providing security.
At Google, we've got something
like more than 600 people
whose job it is to protect
our cloud infrastructure.
So overall, as with
any cloud service,
much of the heavy
lifting is designing
a durable, secure, scalable
cloud is outsourced.
So it lets you focus on
what you're doing best.
Would you say, Jeff, that those
key requirements-- scalability,
durability,
availability-- are some
of the key tenets that people
who are managing media assets
are looking for?
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely.
The opportunity to be able
to get out any file any time
is super valuable.
The example I can give would
be-- I was on a production
where there was a
directorial change,
and they needed
access to a file.
DAVE ELLIOTT: That
never happens.
JEFF KEMBER: Never happens.
Directors never
change their mind.
So in that context, we
needed to bring an asset
back online that had been
moved off of the fast storage,
essentially.
And the version was available,
but we had to pull it back,
and it was going to take
about a day and a half
to get that data,
just because it
was in another office and such.
So when I moved to another
firm, where 100% of the data
was online, in
terms of archival,
we were able to
restore the data back
in just a couple of minutes.
You could just change
your shot directory,
go over to where you
needed to find the file,
and pull it back.
And that emulates the
exact work use model
that we have for
Google Cloud Platform.
You can go and
pull the files back
in just a couple of
seconds, and you have access
to the entire data set.
So the cost savings
on the several days
of people time and
schedule time-- wall clock,
as we call it-- was huge.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great.
Yeah.
Yeah, I've heard types of those
stories over and over again.
It's the accessibility, the
availability, of the data,
and then what you
can do with it,
and the time that you save in
trying to pull that data back
is one of the key benefits
of having an object store,
and having a cloud object store.
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely.
When you look at the
total cost of ownership
for on-premise storage,
in terms of people time
and the number of
days-- if you're
on a schedule of any
kind, and you can add up
the salaries of all the
people, and add that
to your total cost of
overhead, and every day it
takes you longer to
complete it, because you're
pulling storage, either your
offline or your online data,
to try and find it,
that's all real cost.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great.
Great.
So we've talked a little
bit about the requirements
for media, and managing
media files and media assets.
We then moved on to
talk a little about how
object store is a different
approach that really meets
a lot of those requirements.
And then how cloud
object store is really
an even better approach.
So if you're managing
media assets,
or if you will in the future, I
guess you may ask the question,
you know, why Google?
And what's unique about Google?
So now I'd like to transition
into how Google, and Google
Cloud Storage, is different.
Google's had to cope with
massive amounts of data,
because of its grand scale.
Google services
are truly global,
generating exabytes
and exabytes of data.
A secret to Google's continuing
success stems from the fact
that Google was able to operate
at this scale before anyone
else, and at price points order
of magnitudes less expensive
than competitors.
So as a result, there are
a few distinct advantages
to our scale and our experience.
Google Cloud Storage lets
you store your media assets
on a globally available,
highly secure and efficient
infrastructure.
Our object store is
differentiated in several ways.
First, we deliver massive,
massive scalability.
Have I said that yet?
JEFF KEMBER: You have.
DAVE ELLIOTT:
Massive scalability.
Have I said lots and
lots of exabytes?
JEFF KEMBER: Yeah.
Many.
How many?
DAVE ELLIOTT: Many, many, many.
I can't tell you exactly, but
many, many, many, and growing
rapidly.
We've as much capacity
as anyone needs.
One customer came
to us a while ago
and asked for several
hundred petabytes,
because they couldn't procure
storage quickly enough,
and they said they wanted
to grow into maybe a couple
exabytes.
Now, as a storage guy,
that's a lot of storage.
That is an unbelievable
amount of storage.
And we honestly didn't
have any concerns.
JEFF KEMBER: No.
When they asked if they could
have an exabyte of data,
we could arrogantly
respond with,
how many exabytes
would you like?
DAVE ELLIOTT: Yes, exactly.
Second, our global network.
Our global network is
a huge differentiator.
We've got built-in EdgeCast
capabilities, where
we keep your data on our network
as long as we possibly can,
and we automatically store
replicas near where objects
are most frequently requested.
So this means better
availability, and, hence,
a better user experience,
customer experience,
with your media assets.
Our network, as I
mentioned before,
has more than 100 Edge locations
in 33 countries for caching.
You'll be tested on this.
133.
Keep those numbers.
JEFF KEMBER: It's a quiz.
DAVE ELLIOTT: And
we're the only cloud
provider that actually has
laid cables across both oceans.
JEFF KEMBER: So can
you talk a little bit
about the use case--
I have data in Europe,
and I want to read
it in America,
and then I want to read
it in Singapore as well?
Can you talk a little bit
about how the buckets work?
DAVE ELLIOTT: Well,
really, it comes down to,
you know, a key
differentiator, as you
talked about the
requirements for media assets
to be global in nature, right,
the person in India or Chicago
or Singapore needing
access to these.
JEFF KEMBER: Right.
Because the work is often
done in multiple locations
and delivered
elsewhere, or globally.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Or the customer.
Or the customer is in
multiple locations.
You may be web serving, you
may be serving out images,
or you may be serving
out videos, right?
The customer might be
in various locations.
And because we have our own
network-- we own our network,
it's one of the
huge advantages--
we've been pioneers in creating
ways to best optimize data
movement across large distances.
So for a customer that does
have a global operation, that
wants global access
to their data,
that's really one of
our key differentiators.
In addition to the
network, we also
are optimized for
reading very large files.
So we've optimized for
server side throughput,
meaning we simply are faster
in reading large files.
And this really comes from our
legacy in YouTube, in photos,
in Google Play, and that
means that your customers have
a better experience when
they use your media.
The fourth reason
is our pricing.
It's both low and
simple to understand.
We have frequently declining
prices, as opposed to,
say, again as a storage
guy, purchasing storage
hardware that has got to be
capitalized over three years.
And on average, we're 13% to
15% lower than our closest cloud
competitor.
And you know, the feedback that
I get so much from customers
is it's just much
simpler to understand.
The fifth major thing I'll call
out for Google Cloud Storage
differentiators is what I'm
just calling value added
services that can be
applied against your data
when it's in our cloud.
This goes back to your
accessibility comment
earlier, Jeff, where if
you can apply services
against the data, you can create
more value for your customers.
So massive scalability, global
network, large read file
throughput, pricing,
and these value
added services,
which I'll let you
talk about in a couple minutes.
Make sense?
JEFF KEMBER: It does.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great.
So I just briefly wanted to
introduce Google Cloud Storage,
the actual service itself.
We've got three flavors--
Standard, Durable Reduced
Availability, and
Nearline Storage.
They all come with 11
9s durability target,
and they primarily differ
in price and availability.
Standard Storage offers
99.9% availability SLA.
It's ideal for workloads
that require performance
availability and durability.
So it's sort of the standard,
maybe the premium one.
Durable Reduced Availability
is exactly what it says.
It's highly durable, and it has
a slightly reduced availability
SLA at 99%.
So it's ideal for
workloads that can accept
the occasional unavailability.
So for instance,
batch workloads.
Finally, Nearline Storage is
our newest storage offering.
And this is ideally designed
as a cool storage pool.
This is only a penny
a gig per month,
but it comes with a penny
read penalty per gig,
and it's ideal for
infrequently accessed media,
such as backup files,
or even archive files.
So with that, Jeff,
I'd love for you
to talk about that
fifth thing I mentioned
on the previous slide, which
was the value added services.
So we talked a lot about the
benefits of moving to an object
store, the benefits
of moving to a cloud,
and the benefits of moving
to Google's infrastructure.
But where I think a lot
of excitement is today
is what can you do with the
data once it's in the cloud,
once it's in our cloud.
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely.
One of the really cool
things about Google
is the leadership, and the
lead that we have in machine
learning technology.
It is not an overly
exciting conversation
to say what does
a gig cost and--
DAVE ELLIOTT: Hey, wait.
Hold on a second.
JEFF KEMBER: Well, it can be.
But for me, what's
more compelling
is things like the Cloud
Translate API that we have.
The ability to have 80-plus
languages available.
You can put one language
in, auto language detection,
you can get another
language out,
and that works across both
text as well as speech.
So we have a Cloud Speech API.
And that will allow you to
have both batch, as well
as streaming, audio.
So as people are
familiar with, talking
to your phone, that
can be in one language,
we can do a translate
to text for that.
We can do a actual language
translation with that.
And using the Cloud
Natural Language API,
we can then do a context
awareness of what was said,
what was relevant
about that, and be
able to deconstruct
the language,
and get the sentiment of
what the user is looking for.
DAVE ELLIOTT: So this
sounds like a corner case.
It sounds like
something that may not
apply to a lot of people.
But the concept that
there's this service that's
a really innovative service
that you're applying now
against your data, that you
otherwise couldn't have done,
if it were just sitting
on a tape somewhere,
I think that's
really compelling.
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely.
Yeah.
From an imagery
standpoint, I'd encourage
you to download Google Photos.
It's free.
It's available for
iOS and Android.
You can choose to compress your
images a little bit with JPEG,
and there's no limit
on what you can upload,
if you choose that option.
And the nice thing
about it is you
can put thousands, and
many, many thousands, tens
of thousands, of images up.
And the server on the back end
will do the metadata analysis
for you.
So if you type in Golden Gate
Bridge, or you type in cat,
or any of the search terms
for imagery that you may have,
you'll be amazed at the
accuracy and the speed
with which the imagery
can be presented to you.
So the Vision API is fantastic.
You can feed it a
significant amount of imagery
and get back highly
relevant, scored metadata.
And it comes to you with
a percentage of accuracy.
It includes face detection.
It includes emotion.
You can decide if someone
is angry or sad or pensive.
There's all sorts of
different complexities
built in to the model.
You can show it an
image of two kittens,
and it will tell you what
kind of kittens they are.
It's a really, really
compelling use case.
But what's interesting
to me is taking
a massive multi-petabye or
multi-hundred-petabye archive
that you may have, an
onlining that onto the cloud,
and then running metadata
analysis against it
with the Vision API.
That allows you to,
then, get at that data.
It becomes cataloged.
It becomes useful.
You're able to monetize that.
And you're able to
either resell it, or make
it available to
consumers, or make
it available to your
employees in the company,
depending on the type of data.
And that's just the current
roadmap of what we have.
There's more products coming
soon, backed by our machine
learning technology.
We also have BigQuery
and Big Data analytics.
Google is extremely adept at
handling large amounts of data
with huge numbers of queries per
second, to be able to data mine
and come up with relevant
responses on massive data
sets, the queries you have.
So if you have large data
that you want to work with,
please use our tools.
They are really fantastic.
In addition, we also
offer transcoding
for media use cases.
If you have images or
video that is in one format
and you need it in another,
we offer everything
from roll your own
ffmpeg solutions
to fully managed backed
solutions with partners.
And the transcoding
use cases, again,
is especially compelling.
It runs extremely well
on our per-minute cloud.
And the massive amount of
storage we have means you
can transcode
everything in parallel
and be able to
deliver it globally.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Exactly.
So these are some good
examples of, once you
move your data to the cloud, you
can apply things like machine
learning, analytics.
You can potentially apply
other innovative services
that are coming from
Google in the future that
really creates some
differentiation based
upon your data.
JEFF KEMBER: Absolutely.
You can also roll
your own, as well.
Our open source TensorFlow
product is, well, open source.
You can download it,
make your own graphs,
and you can run your own models
against your data as well.
We're all about
open, so if you want
to run containers locally,
and then run them on data
you have in the cloud
that's fully portable.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great, great.
So we've talked about some of
the differentiators of GCS.
And now, let's take a second
and dive into, or at least talk
a little bit about, so how are
customers actually using this?
I mean, who's using
Google Cloud Storage?
And who's using cloud storage
generally, the object store?
Are they managing media files,
and what kind of companies
are doing that?
JEFF KEMBER: Great.
Well, we have Vimeo, which is
a very popular video streaming
service.
We have Snapchat
for social media.
We have Spotify for music
streaming, Ubisoft for gaming.
We have WiX for websites.
We have Egnyte for file sharing,
Khan Academy that everyone
is familiar with.
Some fantastic large
videos available there.
In addition, JDI for
file sharing as well.
DAVE ELLIOTT: Great, great.
So those are some
great brand names
that are using Google
Cloud Storage for storing
and managing their media assets.
So I mean, with that, let's talk
a little bit about next steps.
So if you're managing
media assets,
or if you will in the
future, where to get started.
So there's several
patterns we've
seen on how people get
started using Google Cloud
Storage for managing
their media assets.
First, serving globally.
So our multiregional,
geo-redundant storage,
lightning fast network,
large file read throughput
performance, and scale makes
GCS an ideal storage pool
for serving media files.
Second, transcoding
and data processing.
So our regional DRA,
ability to burst workloads,
again, our global network,
our Envato services,
make this great for
some of the services
that Jeff mentioned
earlier, layering
on top of your media files.
And third, archiving
and disaster recovery.
So with low predictable price,
including no ingress fees,
consistent set of APIs
across all three tiers,
and an instant
on-demand access, make
this an ideal service for
archiving and disaster
recovery.
JEFF KEMBER: That's
an excellent point.
With Nearline, we've
reduced the latency down,
so it's incredibly quick.
It's under a second for read.
And we've also removed
the throttling on Egress.
So the larger the
size of pipe you have,
the more quickly, obviously,
we can send some of the data
to you.
And that high
predictability allows
you to know what it would cost.
If you want to bring back
400 terabytes of data,
you know how long it'll take,
and you know what it'll cost.
And that's really
important in a DR scenario.
DAVE ELLIOTT: You're
exactly right.
It's not just a question
of low price or low cost,
of storing your assets
for a long period of time,
but the fact that you have
predictability on recovery
is a key aspect that
customers seem to really like.
So with that, I'm
going to wrap up.
If you're managing media, if
you're managing media assets,
cloud storage,
Google Cloud Storage,
offers you a low cost
solution that can scale,
scale, scale, let you
focus on what you do best
to differentiate your business.
The great thing about
cloud is it's easy to try.
I recommend the try,
train, and engage process.
Information is plentiful online.
And we're here to help
you be successful.
Thanks for joining us today.
JEFF KEMBER: Thanks
for watching.
[MUSIC PLAYING]